[Music]
according to the Food and Agriculture
Organization roughly one third of the
food produced for human consumption
either get lost or wasted every year
that's approximately 1.3 billion tons
I'm sure all of us have thrown away
rotten vegetables expired products or
left overs reducing food waste does not
only save the environment but it will
also help you to save lots of money and
time in the long run so how can you play
your part I'm gonna share with you 10
really simple food hacks to help you
save money and also to reduce food
wastage first freeze ripe fruits so
instead of allowing those fresh fruits
to rot you can prolong their lives by
slicing them up place into ziplock bags
and freeze them up this will keep well
in the freezer for months and this will
also help to retain the nutrients in the
fruits frozen fruits can be blended to
make fruit smoothies nice cream and they
can even be added into your baked goods
to make healthy cakes and also muffins
knowing this trick can help you save
lots of money by purchasing discounted
fruits and vegetables which are about to
go off when you do your grocery shopping
next save the bones and left over
vegetables instead of throwing away
bones or forgetting your leftover
vegetables cook them you can turn them
into a really tasty bowl of soup without
any added stalks or preservatives simply
place at the unwanted bones and pieces
of vegetables into a pot and allow all
the ingredients to slowly simmer for 30
to 45 minutes natural bone broth
promotes healing to the body such as
protecting the joints increasing bone
strength and also it is great for your
guts this is an ancient remedy which has
been used by many different cultures
plus it is food for the Soul
you can even cube the stock and add into
your cooking later on next turn extra
veggies into a vegetable soup another
thing you can do with the leftover
vegetables is to mix them all together
and make creamy vegetable soup puree the
dish can be eaten on its own or you can
use it as a sauce for your pasta or meat
dishes now if you really hate eating
your vegetables this is a really simple
and great way to meet your five a day
without feeling like you have to keep
chewing and chewing on your veggies you
can even cook them in bulk and freeze
them for later on another great way to
prolong the life of vegetables is to
turn them into pickles for instance
slice up cabbage and turn it into
sauerkraut
fermented vegetables will keep for many
months if stored in an airtight
container at the right temperature
fermented vegetables make nutrients more
readily available they promote a healthy
gut and contains probiotics since 70 to
80 percent of the immune system lies in
the gut it is extremely important to
have a healthy gut and this can even
promote weight loss turn stale bread
into croutons is your bread getting
stale instead of throwing them out why
not slice them into small cubes brush
with a little bit of butter sprinkle
with garlic salt and bake them to make
yourself some croutons and they go
perfectly in your soups and salads fries
extra herb into ice cubes don't know
what to do with your leftover Hubbs easy
chop them up place into ice cube trays
add some water or oil and freeze them up
to make herb cubes and you can add this
into your cooking later on you can even
do this to the fruits and make infused
water which leads onto my next point
use lemon peels to make infused water if
you're someone who squeezes fresh lemon
or orange juice and discard the puce
well next time save the peels because
that's where most of the essential
vitamins minerals and enzymes are simply
infuse into your water or tea and gain
the benefits drinking this on a regular
basis can help to flush out toxins for
all you dog lovers here's a remedy you
must know I like to save my egg shells
and let them dry out then simply use a
grinder and grind the shells into really
fine powder should one of my dogs get
diarrhea I would just sprinkle a couple
of teaspoons of the eggshell powder in
to their food and the diarrhea would
just magically go away you have to try
this for your dogs the next hack is to
turn left overs into a one-pot dish
cooked way too much for dinner
well don't throw anything away turn
those little bits of leftovers into a
one pot dish by mixing everything
together and take it with you to work
for lunch be daring an experiment
because hey you might just create a new
dish that tastes delicious
the final hack is something I practice
often use a spray bottle for your oil
instead of roughly estimating and
pouring oil directly from the bottle
onto the pan and having way too much oil
just to coat the pan transfer the
cooking oil into a spray bottle using a
spray bottle will help you to reduce on
your calorie intake because you will
tend to use a lesser amount this will
also make your food less greasy which
means you will consume less fat overall
and of course this will help you to lose
weight so the next time you want to
throw food out from your fridge apply
this really simple food hacks to reduce
on food waste
save money and also to eat healthier we
should all play our part to reduce food
wastage and save the environment what
other food hacks do you practice let me
know in the comments below be sure to
like this video and share this video on
subscribe to my youtube channel if you
haven't yet done it and hit the
notification button so that you would
get notified every time I upload a new
video all the best